d'abord non je voudrais montrer michel
cymes regarder ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
michel cymes qui s'est fait vacciner en
direct regarder très moi j'estime que
c'est un levier de confiance il ya
important je pense qu'olivier ferrand
est là pour les saluer pour saluer
l'initiative est pas pour organiser
derrière une mise en scène ou qui quand
bien même il est médecin reste une mise
en scène politique puisque aux yeux des
français il est avant tout ministre de
la santé je me dis que si je le fais pas
peut-être que les français vont se dire
si lui de la feb a on peut le faire
aussi mais bon moi je sais pas ce que je
fais de la télé que voilà j'ai la chance
d'avoir une petite popularité mais c'est
aussi un message que je fais passer à
mes confrères médecins vous avez le dr
armand sur le plateau moi je pense que
tous les médecins doivent eux aussi se
faire vacciner
moi je les fais il faut que vous le
fassiez aussi il ya jean michel cohen
aussi mon pote jean michel cohen et jean
michel cohen qui s'est fait vacciner
chez jean-marc dans morandini live
regardez mon poto jean-michel fini
aujourd'hui je vous monde c'est d'une
simplicité biblique
c'est un vaccin comme vous le connaissez
tous petit nettoyage en bout de femme
charmante et par une interne tout à fait
charmant petit jeu les recevoir mon
élection je vous tiendrai au courant
jour après jour de ce qu'il va se passer
on verra si une demande de le passer à
la télé mais voilà assez simple aiguille
la dose est déjà prête
bien sûr aucune douleur j'ai rien senti
d'une douceur exemple mais voilà en
primo vaccination ce genre face dans
trois semaines
j'adore jean michel cohen et vous à
faire dire est qu'il nous fait une pub
alors est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ces et très médiatique qui se font
vacciner antenne je vous pose la
question est ce que ça vous donne envie
est ce que ça vous rassure géraldine
alors oui c'est très bien évidemment
c'est un très bon exemple
malgré tout ils ont respectivement 63
ans pour cymes et 61 pour jean michel
cohen donc ils sont pas dans le critère
des pizzas sont magnifiques pour
l'oreille moi je vois que ma mère clé
elle est en activité à plus de 65 ans
avec quatre jours quelle galère pour ce
faire vacciner et elle est à risque non
je trouve que c'est assez c'est un peu
compliqué quand même de voir les
médecins qui ont une sorte de facilité
parce qu'ils sont médiatiques et ça me
semble aussi gérer ce message
paris salon et son scénariste plutôt
bien sûr il ya une ligne mais bien de
sortir là un instant de 200
personnalités qui veulent se faire
personnalité quand corps malade julie
gayet jean personnes et qui veulent se
faire personnalité si oui guillaume
moins chaud que l'idée de michel cymes
et les bonnes parce qu'il veut se servir
de sa crédibilité de médecin pour se
faire vacciner
le seul problème si on muselle prennent
aussi ouais le seul problème c'est qu'il
n'a pas été très crédible sur le colis
non c'est qu'il a dit beaucoup de propos
qui était un peu fou il a tout vu en
amérique il est quand même médecin il
était très présent dans les médicaments
l'idée est bonne les sous que c'est pas
la bonne humeur ça on va dire la vérité
c'est le médecin médiatique ccc tiens
c'est pas grave il y en ad'autres giral
15 mars et j'adore marcher 10 km et le
médecin le plus connu de s'allonger
cgi je dirige en termes de crédibilité
sur le commissaire mais la meilleure des
secours alors arrivé servant de vacciner
quand un mec faire plus ça c'est
franchement on sait qu'ici on n'aime pas
forcément beaucoup mais effectivement
lui et maxime sert bien sûr il averti
après qu'il ai déconné qui n'est pas
déclarée sûre connaît-il certains
immigrés connaît d'ailleurs il a jamais
dit de caudry c'est que tout le monde
regarde et il a été relevé par apolline
de malherbe à la journaliste de bfm tv
de m6 aussi qu'ils adorent pauline qu'un
formidable
regardez ce qu'ils avaient non mais ce
qui manque tout simplement en france
c'est aussi qu'ils aient des fortes
personnalités qui décide de se faire
vacciner plusieurs auditeurs le disait
hier vous en souvenez sans doute qu'ils
nous avaient appelé au 32 16 en 10 ans
mais au fond pourquoi il n'y a pas de
publicité
on a des pages de pub en permanence sur
toutes les radios et les télés pour
vanter les gestes barrières et y en a
aucune pour vanter cette campagne de
vaccination il n'y a pas je sais pas
brigitte macron brigitte macron elle est
dans l'est dans les tranches d'âge ça
serait formidable je pense ce serait en
tout cas intéressant et ça pourrait
peut-être aussi créé une sorte de
mouvement au moins se dire ben saad et
inquiète ceux qui sont angoissés si on
la voyait son exemple en fait ça
montrerait l'exemple bernard montiel
non mais c'est bien brigitte macro mais
se sait ce qu'elle est capable de le
faire mais ce serait sûrement une très
bonne idée maintenant je peux pas
répondre à sa place
alors ce qu'on peut dire ce qu'on va
dire comme on dit toujours des
personnalités aussi fortes justement
comme madame a
que sait si elle le fait on va dire ah
ben ça y est les pistonnés elle elle a
eu par exemple ça n'a pas eu à mister
you ça va ça met des polémiques pas dire
ça de la reine d'angleterre
si sa résille polémique sur clinique je
suis d'accord avec vous et moi je suis
désolé les 200 personnalités qui veulent
se faire vacciner moi ça me choque parce
que effectivement aujourd'hui à des
soignants bien sûr encore un pas accès
aux vaccins et sont et qui sont en
première ligne face les malades du co
lead donc et il ya un truc qui tourne
pas rond car il faut dire que nous
étions d'accord je le rappelle pas ce
qu'on me le demande souvent là sur
twitter nous on est prêt à le faire ce
mois n'a pas encore obtenu
l'autorisation nous on n'est pas
prioritaire donc c'est un peu difficile
pour nous de nous faire vacciner arrêté
à jerada là où ce serait forte pour
brigitte macron c'est qu'elle est malgré
tout grand mère mais justement il ya
plein de grands parents qui voient pas
leurs petits enfants et elle pourrait
dire mais moi j'en ai marre j'en ai
marre de plus voir mes petits enfants
j'ai pu voir de plus voir mes enfants et
donc je veux me faire vacciner pour être
protégés pour avoir reprendre une vie
normale
gevrey voilà je trouvais ça me revient
alors en parlant d actes simples et à
mon ami gad elmaleh le number one qui
vient de poster une vidéo touchante et
très très drôle avec ses parents et
voulait savoir qui se ferait vacciner
avec dans la famille s'il n'y avait pas
assez de vaccins regard des mamans on
est cinq dans la famille ok on les cinq
imagine imagine on a quatre vaccins qui
ce qui se fait vacciner
pourquoi parce que je vois tu donnes ton
bac 5
il est déjà difficile
j'ai même pas si ça va marcher
extradé il rentre à qui je fais de gros
bisous je savais que je les aime très
très fort galilée exceptionnel